skated around Josh Anderson makoy to
poock a shot and a save by Al of the
last 38 short-handed situations Coffield a shot
and a save by San he reads the game so well he
Square to a lot of shots Josh Anderson a glose
save by Swan and the steel by Josh Anderson he
closes tries to rip with pav zaka 720 by zaka
gets the puck back from Carlo and a save by
Allen march on to makoy Paka slap pass to
Maran and Allen a good save a real good
save pass knock teas off man didn't get all of
it make sure that sticks in one piece Coy out
of the corner saucer pass to poock back to Coy
poock to makoy Nako scores and that's baran's
500 ass assist of his career easy shot that
led to the Penalty where POS was driving the
net again the shot mentality particularly on
the five on three and they going to love where
maoy shoots this pu from no reason to be held by
the Blue Line you shot in the ice Forks it back
to lorai a quick spin to get around Monahan
into the crease p and two tries opportunities
in both directions we'll start with Boston
a little spin move up at the blue line and
the attack of the net by Mason lry Dan hind
in second n against that Maran this way and
that water bugging tipped and forward took a
swing but Brandon Gallagher a close save by
Swingman tries to go far side now get with the
right P but when the Bruins got that fiveman
cycle going Jack in the offensive Co too back
to Coy he zooms into space and tries the short
side Jake Allen had no idea where the rebound
went just had to hold his ground and not get
beat on that short side shot by coil nice
play by The Brew final minute of the first
period C field to the other Corner Cole CHS the
line Frederick on the net Drive Cole finds Carlo
the r shot scores TI in the high slot by TR
Frederick and it's 20 Boston but now you're
in the final minute of the period and you give
up a goal on a little shot from the point on a
redirect you give the defenseman kylo too
much time and space you give Frederick too
much space in the slot there's a lot of red
white and blue back in the defensive Zone but
nobody's picking anybody up to pivots and the
block by loai Suzuki slips it to New hook and
a great save by San trips apparently on the blue
line zaka to lindol Saka one timer slow goes down
and the change up Beats Jake Allen it's 30-0 G
just kind of trips over the skates of linol on
lol's back check I thought that was a good non
call and then with numbers coming across the
Blue Line nice little game of catch between
lyol and zaka zaka he doesn't flush this one
timer but it deflects off the Stick of Jordan
Harris it changes the pace of the puck and it
changes the angle against Katie gly good body
position from [Music] Steen lco a turnaround
shot slap kovski
Suzuki new hook Wheels it Suzuki oh slap
kosi great hands a one-time and Montreal
has life pile Play Chances early in the first
and a couple other big time stops by SW when
Montreal had Puck possession in the offensive
zone Bruins had a couple opportunities to make
a play in order to get an exit and everybody
seems like they're in decent shape in terms of
protecting the goal [Applause] scoring cross
ice pass slap kski knocks it down one shot
on the Montreal power play and here's Trent
Frederick he scores fresh out of the box it's
41 in between Montreal's goal and the
goal margin spreading to three you know
the goals in terms of numbers might not be
there for Jake de bruss but he makes a big
play he going to steal that puck along
the wing ball boards just as the penalty
expires sh Kirk's Drive Puck loose
and Jake Allen Smothers it pono's
able to fight for that loose Puck as he
steps inside the penalty killing unit of
the Canadians gets a shot away there's
the one-time by shaton Kirk Lindholm
had a one-time Frederick was looking for
goal number three Jake de brus Works G's
side denied by
Allen Marine back to makoy cross the
rink to poock Maran to B re St it's 5 to
one at the very end they got of spread
everybody out and that allows both Maran
and V dreams like to be the only ones
in and around Jake Allen B recognizes it
I'm going to get it in that area because
we've spread out the penalty killers and
marot makes a play on the puck with his
body and allows it to go Suzuki wins it
back Coffield slapped out of the slot by
Heen mat takes it right to the crease and
swiming blocks entry such great skating
ability he's really grown into a very good
defenseman a very good player a dominant
player he's obviously the alpha dog for
this Montreal Canadians group just attacks
the net just can't finish up the pass by
kovic caved in by loo slap kovski Dvorak and
a great save by swayan and kova savic knocks
in the rebound it's 5-2 with four and a
half to go yeah and it's really too bad
I mean the fourth Line's been uh pretty good
here tonight you don't like to give up goals
in this situation Montreal going to the end
and kova Civic the defenseman he's up ice he
attacks the net dorak makes a nice play
to him underneath the Stick of makoy the
initial stop by Jeremy Swan Saka and Van
reike score also and a five to two final